all right i uh i owe you guys an apology
prior to hitting a million subscribers i
made a promise to you
that once we hit we would release the mi
morena song
i didn't do so there are reasons why i
couldn't and reasons why i couldn't tell
you guys
the song doesn't actually belong to
random artists it belongs to my best
friend
this man's like a brother to me i've
been supporting him he's been supporting
me for
a long time
the story behind the song is that
initially he'd sent it to some famous
artists
for them to potentially use and um
when he sent it to them as a batch of
songs
none of them got picked up but then he
sent me what he'd sent them he's like
hey this is what i made for them
take a listen and i was like cool yeah
let me hear them and i picked out that
song specifically and i'm like yo this
shit's fire like i can i can do
something with this like this is a real
some good stuff and you know i think as
artists
it's hard because we deal with a lot of
self-confidence issues and it's hard to
believe in your work especially if you
don't have tremendous amount of like you
know success on big platforms
he definitely goes through through bouts
of that and i always want to support him
i like to support the people around me
so even the previous outro songs are
either made by him or other people i
know locally i like to
i like to keep things in-house if i can
so he didn't think much of it he's like
yeah if you want to use it go ahead and
i said cool when i put that [ __ ] at the
end of songs and you guys started
picking up on it y'all started harassing
me
trying to get me to put it out and i was
sending him all your responses and all
your comments i would take screenshots
and he would be like yo i can't believe
i've never had this much
traction so for me it was like a bit of
a heartwarming thing
um because i've just seen my brother
my best friend who's like struggled for
so long get some form of recognition not
because
i said the song is great but because you
guys genuinely liked it so for me
it made me
it made me feel good
to know that he could finally recognize
that his work matters
and that people do vibe with it he just
they just haven't had a chance to hear
it
um and so i spoke to him i'm like yo
let's make this like a full two
two minute length song because the
original one was just a reference track
that he sent
um and so we went through that process
and it was crumbling together great
uh but you know sometimes you suffer
from imposter syndrome and this process
you gotta go through so for me
i just have to be patient with him and
to give him time to get to that mental
space where he feels ready to do so
and uh even though it's taken quite some
time and we're well past
a million uh we finally gotten there but
that's not his fault
that you guys didn't get what you
deserve that's my fault it's my fault
for
promising to you something that i didn't
actually have
yet and uh that for that i have to
take some level responsibility you know
and so
making this video let you guys know and
to let you know that the video will be
out
uh as well as the song will be out on
spotify and other platforms
uh later this week and uh
yeah uh you know i just i just want him
to be heard
and i want it to be done well so uh
thank you guys for your patience i know
it's not what you guys want to hear but
it is coming so
my apologies and uh yeah guys when you
guys hear it share it
like it not for me uh for me personally
but uh if you really like what he does
then uh show him some love because
sometimes that's all it needs to keep us
a little bit going a little bit further
so
thank you guys you guys are awesome and
uh
that's all